screamo yo Nino praia da okay Mozambique
is a soup pot oh you need a state
avocado you do this Kyoto chicken on KDE
beginning stage so in this mode it's
actually four players each player
chooses up to three pokemon and battles
with one at a time in this video here
we're just doing one pokemon for the
sake of time yo yo yo honey chicken on
the SkyDome oh hey kono kimochi no
porque manga ceviche tostada Taurasi I
Chiodo Marines so how this actually
works with how it determines the winners
this is a free-for-all battle but
whenever one of the trainers when the
first trainer to lose all of his or her
pokemon that signals the end of the
battle a toast up okay 10 cos bull Gator
no kodou okay ma no cotton ball ka gai
qi gong OE Piazza shows a politeness and
then once the battle is over once the
first person loses all the pokemon is
then the to determine the winner had the
game tallies up each player's how many
pokemon they've defeated and also how
many pokemon they have remained on their
team and whoever has the highest number
is the winner without rail I think it's
really interesting what this is going to
do for strategy as folks are playing
because generally speaking when you're
thinking about how you're going to
switch off your pokemon to fight another
trainer it's only a one-on-one situation
so you can look at their Pokemon saying
okay I've got this pokemon that's going
to be strong against this one but you're
worried about two other opponents here
so you really have to think about who's
gonna fare best against three other
brother section yeah but now no deaf boy
you know either kojima-san so far to my
takes no come under al some to do that
if I'm on Yom Kippur is Annie ki nahin
connecting on my talk show is over so
listen 80 micante Tokyo state for us ki
did ok monetary otos cocktail oh can I
take a message the favor it is sweet
soup okay my demo honey the shoot you
move it to sleep at all citizens nothing
just a one so it's a free-for-all and of
course you know you could have three
people gang up on one really strong
person or you really have to kind of
determine your strategy about how you're
gonna you know which order you're going
to defeat pokemon who you're going to
focus on so
totally new gameplay back yet is
interesting how much more intense it
feels were amused to just looking at the
trainer in front of me and fighting them
it's on they cycle it still more
trainers they have to pay attention to
everybody study the whole debate and
folks watching era you may have caught
that the trainers there were wearing
different outfits and what we saw with
the the regular player character
dilution off so far we can't really talk
about the hit but worth noticing tomato
God so the check out you know just
kidding anyways i'm not a jameson got a
good idea no I think okay I know SE kya
hai so you can actually customize your
outfits and the in this game as well so
so we're just about out of time but
before we wrap up I was curious now that
you've had a chance to see some family
action for these games how's it been
seeing how Pokemon fans have reacted for
Pokemon Sun and Pokemon moon but you
can't go stationary much like a little
more ma khong cai no I pokemon some hop
bo selecta got a funky Oh Tina hard
single matteo renzi johannes domani
mosca so this is nano Punk I nanigen go
Cara aqune Bonnie shipping or a fish
must a token is on achievements
characters to that scar amo toxin or
hunky today Tim estate much even seat
atoka I know it alighted on the skater
boy epic oh my [ __ ] money soon enter
go to party pokhara sera Neko Shiro
vario miss a Romany ma he's unique Oh
Nina arrow con decorate a motto demo
racine Otto oh yes the friend the
reaction for everyone has been really
great and I get tons of messages and
tweets and everything this being on the
20th anniversary of Pokemon one of the
goals really want to kind of you know
for the future Pokemon really kind of
expand it to even a wider audience and
as I think you we've announced
previously in the addition to the seven
languages we had X Y and Omega Ruby
alpha sapphire we also added to chinese
simplified chinese and traditional
chinese and i think a lot of the
especially from those regions like fans
have really been kind of excited about
it and sending me lots of great messages
and is there anything final that you'd
like to wrap up and say to fans for
watching this dream right now just like
my father message to go to the mascot so
let's nano Maury mahmoud any night our
NGO almost san tomas tarrano day annum
in assam so Thomas medium updated with a
fight so yeah I think Simon moon we're
really doing a lot of new challenges for
us he was Game Freak so I hope it for
one religious we look for
to the games okay a tomar GV Wisconsin
since actor sino director Hashima turret
and aim attacks on Oak Lola tandis que
no sono koe game originated excise duty
good as I so there was a lot of
challenges for me especially as it's the
first time directing an entirely new
generation of Pokemon at Game Freak but
i think we've really brought the game
together it's really turned into
something fantastic and i hope fans
really look forward to it oh yeah i know
i'm definitely looking forward to and
thank you so much for joining us and
giving us some insight into the
development work here I was watching
again that was Pokemon Sun and Pokemon
moon which are coming out from the
Nintendo 3ds family of systems this
November so you don't have to wait too
much longer and please don't go anywhere
in a few moments where actually to be
coming back I'll numis on is going to be
stopping by to show us a gameplay for a
game you might be thinking about Legend
of Zelda breath of the wild so please
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
thank you